the following footage is 20 seconds long
five sentences are spoken that there are
26 words in total you wanted your life
for hers
she's losing time oh and just like that
Superman convinced Batman that what they
were doing was entirely unnecessary to
the plot now I know Lois Lane spoke one
sentence for Superman but Superman could
have easily said that if Batman's foot
wasn't on his throat and there were
plenty of times where Batman's foot was
not on his throat where Superman could
have said his whole thing
much smoother and much faster oh now
let's look at one more thing in detail
before Superman starts talking
Batman has not given a [ __ ] this entire
time and is about to finally kill
Superman did you see that instantly off
of a simple choice of five words Batman
decides to put the fighting on hold and
actually hear Superman out now let's
look at how many times Superman could
have easily at least got him Batman to
stop fighting and hear him out 15
seconds of them not talking and the Man
of Steel could have prevented this
pointless fight God knows how long
Superman was already hovering above
Batman before we cut to this shot
if you wanted your life for her well
Here I am Bruce please I was wrong you
have to listen to me don't you
understand there's no time
I understand
another 16 seconds of silence sir man
could have easily shouted or just flown
above him and explained all this to
Batman in a few seconds if you wanted
your life oh no no no that's fine you
think Clark would take these next 11
seconds to stop this schoolyard fight
and try to get to work on saving his mom
you wanted your life for hers she's
losing time
hey now I wanted it you'd be dead
already
Filmore fine
fine see this moment is especially
annoying to me because Superman has
already wasted enough time within the
one hour he has and in this very moment
Batman is scared and Superman has full
control meaning he has plenty of time
here to now really tell Batman what the
[ __ ] is going on weakened Superman can
totally talk to him now
but now let's continue fighting
you wanted your life for her she's
losing time I'm moving past this moving
past system and passes but your parents
taught you mean something
it's true here for a reason tonight my
parents taught me a different lesson
dying in the gutter throws hell